[موسيقى]
بدون شك بحكم تجوالك ربما كل مكان كل مكان
او كل مدينه طالما عم نحكي عن الخط وايضا
يعني يملي عليك يملي عليك
لوحه معينه في التعامل مع الخط ومع الحرف
مع اللون مثل ما شاهدنا الان في اصيله
الجداريه يعني الجداريه بتشبه اصيله بشكل
من الاشكال فيها بحر وفيها الوانه وفيها
الازرق وفيها فيها المناخات كلها
هل هذا صحيح انه الامكنه ايضا تفرض على
بشتغل خاصه بهالمطرح بالنسبه لي صحيح هذا
مئه بالمئه صحيح يعني اللوحه باصيله هي
تشبه اصيله هي بنت اصيله لو بمكان اخر
ممكن خرج معي شيء اخر مختلف وامانه
بالزياره الاولى لاصيله عملت لوحه هي صباح
في اصيله فكان يبدو هذا القصر الذي نحن
فيه
شامخ بالوسط وحوله الكتابات تطوف ف المكان
بصريا ووجدانيا
يلهم الفنان طيب واين الذاكره ماذا بقي
منها في هذا في شغلك بتحضر الذاكره
الامكنه الاولى امكنه الطفوله امكنه
النشاه يعني تلك الالوان تلك الصوتيات تلك
الحروف يعني اطياف الاشياء يعني تلقي
بظلالها على عملي لكن الحضور للواقع هو هو
يعني ممكن احيانا اشتغل على استحضار شيء
معين يعني بعملي اللي عملته بكم سنه
بالبرغمون بمتحف برلين عن سوريا حديقه
التاريخ اضطريت لاني استرجع سوريا كامله
استرجع تاريخ 7000 سنه بعمل فني طبعا عمل
كان يعني له وقع عجيب وكبير وكان يعني كان
المفروض مني يعني ارجع اعيد صياغه هذا
التاريخ بتلازم الصوره والحرف